just remember when someone asks you if
you're a god you say yes ghostbusters
2016 and yes I already had this so I
have now finally seen it before I get
into the review proper a couple things I
want to say ahead of time if you follow
this channel at all you know I've been
extremely nervous about this movie
partly because the original Ghostbusters
is my favorite movie of all time I was
gonna be really nervous about any reboot
remake or even proper sequel to this
thing but before I get into this review
there's a couple of things that I want
to say up front and because they may
color what you think of my opinion and I
just want to get them out of the way you
may have seen my earlier video where I
called this up for being rebooted than a
continuation saying I there was nothing
that I had seen that made it clear to me
why this could not be a continuation now
honestly that's still the case I was not
able to sit there and not compare it to
the original in some cases point for
point which in my mind brings up one of
the criticisms that I'm gonna say
legitimately which is that it spends too
much of its first half kind of rehashing
the same points but I mean oh I could
not divorce I could not sit there and
just let it wash over me as its own
thing now with that prejudice noted up
front it's fine I mean honestly that's
it it's fine it's not bad I still can't
say that I really liked it but again
keep in mind my prejudice is taking
completely unto itself it's fine and
fine movies generally break into one of
two categories they're either just
mediocre across the board which would be
something like say x-men apocalypse
where there's nothing really wrong with
it but nothing really stands out as
being great either or there are fine
movies that have things that are good
about them but most of them tend to be
offset somewhat by things that aren't so
good about them and that for me is this
movie and that can sometimes be the more
frustrating option because you see stuff
that works you know like why couldn't
you just keep doing that stuff and not
doing the stuff that didn't work but
that's what happens this is what we go
so what's the plot the plot it the plot
is the first Ghostbusters pretty much
it's not a point for point remake but it
does spend a lot of time rehashing the
same major plot points in terms of
then getting kicked out of academia than
starting up the business on their own
nobody believing them the manifestations
are leading to something bigger etc etc
etc and really eventually I did sort of
settle in and start actually enjoying
the movie it hit a point where I felt
like it was finally doing its own thing
more than just rehashing the old scenes
in with this new style of humor which
I'll come back to in a bit and you know
it finally eventually felt like its own
legitimate story and I checked the time
on my phone well at the point that I
finally felt that and that was an hour
and 15 minutes into the movie so for the
first hour 15 I was kind of annoyed not
actively annoyed like I said it's not
bad it's not terrible but it was going
over all the beats and the points in the
original and that's that's not good
enough and again that brings up why I
feel like this should not have been a
reboot they wouldn't have had to repeat
so many of the same points if they had
built off the old continuity and they
didn't have to reestablish all this junk
they wouldn't have had to go through the
rules of the tech and the ghosts and
they did all they had all they would
have had to do was establish these
characters but eh anyway I'll try I'll
try out to get on that too much I did
mention that the style of the humor is
not to my liking and that's just a
reality of sort of one of the prevalent
and popular ways of doing comedy in
films these days it's what I call
awkwardness comedy and I don't like
awkwardness comedy and awkwardness
comedy it tends to be that the setup for
what the joke is you see it coming and
but the way that they try and milk
humour out of it is just how long
they're willing it to just let it sit
there and let the moment be yeah okay
and some people find that funny and
that's fine I don't I like my humor much
more guerilla style I like it in and out
I like it I like it when the plot is
moving and you find a place to do jokes
I have gone on record and other places
saying that you could strip every single
joke out of the original Ghostbusters
and it would still be a really
interesting movie partly because no
scene exists solely for the purpose of
telling you joke every scene is the
scene you would still need even if
was a movie with no humor in it because
it establishes things about the
characters and moves the plot forward
there are scenes there are chunks in
this version of ghostbusters that exists
for no reason other to generate jokes
and I'm not gonna say you can't do that
but what that means is if the joke falls
flat then the entire scene just hurts
but if you can integrate it into the
story that even if the jokes fall flat
at least the stories at least the scene
still served a purpose I mean I think
mighty example in this one would be
Kevin who's played by Chris Hemsworth is
being interviewed for the secretary
position and that interview scene goes
on a while and it tells us almost
nothing we didn't already figure out
about Kevin or that the movie wouldn't
reiterate later and it has nothing to it
just it's there to generate jokes and if
those jokes don't lame for you it's a
painful scene but look once this thing
hit the our 15 mark and it started with
that was the point at which they figured
out the the leylines and figured out
what was gonna happen next the thing
kind of kicked into high gear for me at
that point it felt more like its own
thing and I was able to get into it and
they kicked in the music they used the
the original theme quite a bit I noticed
that the new song that came out was only
showed up once the classic Ghostbusters
theme is quite prevalent and I like that
but you know the theme is kicking and I
where I really I love it when they are
in time you know it's funny I was I was
afraid I was gonna have to label this a
spoiler review but if you've been
watching the trailers everything I'm
about to tell you've already seen so
again this is another case of the
trailers showing too much but when
they're in Times Square you know kicking
the butts of all these ghosts if that is
a really good section and that whole
segment and the movie has its own life
and its own energy at that point and I
was genuinely enjoying it I suppose I'll
talk about some of the specific
characters as well basically in terms of
the core for it was a very mixed bag for
me first up you've got Melissa McCarthy
who's fine in it but she's not doing
anything here you didn't already see her
doing spy there's Kristen Wiig now and
unfortunately Kristen Wiig is sort of
Luke
lene of that awkwardness comedy that I
talked about and she doesn't very well
but I don't like it as a comedy style so
I did not like her
kate mckinnon was good and fun and
energetic and it didn't completely click
for me it felt a little too many sort of
affectations and it felt a little put on
but she did it well as she was fun to
have there here was the big surprise my
favorite of the four was Leslie Jones I
I was shocked by that because I hated
her in the trailers I she I thought she
was gonna be the worst thing about this
but honestly she's my favorite one
because she feels the most natural she
has a couple of overblown moments like
the whole the power Patty compels you
thing but aside from that and maybe one
other time her jokes feel organically
coming out of the character it feels
like this is something that she's she
would have just said she's not trying to
milk a joke this is just what that
character would say and sometimes it
happens to be funny and that's very much
in keeping with the style of comedy that
the original Ghostbusters have that I
love so much
the effects are fine they're very CGI
but again changing times new technology
I still prefer the old stuff but again
it could be nostalgia the one other
thing I feel the need to plan is that
the the original cast cameos all of them
painful they were shoehorned in they
weren't funny and I'm including Slimer
and Stay Puft Marshmallow Man on those
cameo lists they just none of them
worked
yeah it was fine it does not ruin the
old one as far as remakes or reboots or
whatever of really good originals go in
recent years it's better than Robocop
it's better than Total Recall but it's
still not great I don't love it I
hesitate to say whether or not I like it
but again I'm not gonna call it a bad
movie here's what I'll say and this
might seem contradictory I didn't
particularly like this movie there were
things about I like but the movie
overall it was okay I do hope it gets a
sequel and the reason I hope it gets a
sequel is because I hope that will mean
that they will do a movie where the
whole thing feels like the last hour of
this movie where once they've gotten all
the setup and expository junk out of the
way it was able
just feel like its own thing and I'm
hoping that with this movie behind it if
they get to do a sequel it will get a
whole movie like that and I will be able
to just flat-out enjoy that okay I got
to wrap this up guys I am melting in
this thing because I have to turn the
fan off when I do shoot these I'm I'm
really hot in this and sadly not in the
way that I would like that to be anyways
what were your thoughts on the new
Ghostbusters whatever they were drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it try and keep it respectful
though I know this movie touched a lot
of hot buttons but let's stay nice if
you like my stuff give me a like give me
a subscribe check me out on Twitter
right Council of geeks give a listen to
the council of geeks podcast available
on iTunes and stitcher and until next
time this council is adjourned